Дерево знань в прямому розумінні,
посеред Берліна. У цьому пункті буккросингу
будь-хто може взяти чи залишити щось почитати.
Безкоштовний обмін книжками дуже
популярний у Німеччині, причому не один рік.
Таких книжкових полиць у Берліні - близько сотні,
а користувачів буккросингу – тисячі.
Знайти тут українську книжку, звісно,
рідкість. Тим часом у Німеччині живе близько
130 тисяч українців.
Одна з них – Тетяна Ігнатенко –
мешкає в Берліні два роки. Спочатку вона
привозила книги з України.
Утім, швидко зрозуміла – все, що хочеться почитати – не привезеш.
Дуже важко її сюди привезти. Якщо про фізичну
книжку казати, це дорого. А друге,
що тут скачати не можна, тобто тут є проблеми обмеження якраз
з торентами, як ми знаємо.
І тому тут виникає таке бажання все-таки
не порушувати закон, але і хочеться легально це все-таки читати.
Так виникла ідея - організувати український буккросинг
у німецькій столиці. Книгомани знаходять
один одного у фейсбук-групі “Буккросинг Юкрейн Берлін”,
яка нині налічує близько півтисячі учасників.
Ці знайомства швидко переростають у зустрічі,
а згодом навіть у дружбу. Об'єднує, власне, саме життя  на чужині.
Тетяна втратила своє рідне місто Донецьк через війну на Сході України.
Ірина  в Німеччині нещодавно і не хоче відвикати від старого хобі.
Я обожнюю українську мову і читати українською
для мене – це велике задоволення.
Якими б затятими читачками не були Ірина та Тетяна, цього недостатньо,
щоб україномовна література
зайшла на німецький книжковий ринок, із загальним
обсягом близько 9 мільярдів євро.
Попри це, велику мрію українських берлінців почав втілювати
малий бізнес. Любов Кеменова
відкрила книжкову крамничку
східноєвропейської літератури ОстПост.
Я сама з Росії, мій чоловік словак.
В певний момент ми почали шукати якісну літературу з наших
країн в Берліні й зрозуміли, що ми
не зможемо її знайти. Тому виникла ідея
відкрити такий центр.
Дістати сучасну літературу польською, угорською, російською чи іншими
східноєвропейськими мовами – дуже складно.
Продавати - не дуже рентабельно. Але мрія
Любові – створити осередок східноєвропейської культури в Берліні –
змушує бути винахідливою.
У нас були заходи, де дівчата в’язали шарфи
та просто спілкувалися українською.
Захід пройшов чудово!
У нас є сербсько-хорватська дитяча група,
угорські мовні курси, наприклад. Тобто, ми
стараємося для всіх цих націй створити якісь події,
об'єднуємо Східну Європу. На жаль, український
напрямок в нас поки "шкутильгає".
Аби зарадити ситуації та заохотити українців,
культурний центр OstPost відкрив невеличкий пункт
українського буккросингу. Тепер в української книги
в Берліні є не лише сторінка у Фейсбуці,
але й дах над головою.